je regardais le box office pour préparer
la cérémonie et j'ai remarqué un truc
dingue
les profs ou libye lé la vie d'adèle
quai d'orsay que des bandes dessinées
vous savez quoi
en temps de crise je suis convaincu que
la bd va sauver le cinéma français c'est
vrai un livre c'est souvent écrit en
tout petit parfois même pas en français
alors qu'une bd il ya déjà les dialogues
les décors les costumes ya même le
storyboard on gagne un temps fou j'en
vois qui sourit arnaud je le dis alors
d'accord mesdames et messieurs l'immense
arnaud despléchin est sur le coup pour
veut bd sur laquelle les plus grands se
sont déjà cassé les dents tom tom et
nana psychothérapie d'un amour
impossible à voir nous voilà et puis si
tu cherche quelqu'un pour le rôle de
nana
enfin bref pour remettre le césar de la
meilleure adaptation
cette année dans un souci d'excellence
l'académie a décidé de faire passer un
casting pour trouver le remettant idéal
je vous propose d'en découvrir les
premières images en exclusivité sa
liberté
donc voila tu sais qu'avec l'académie on
a pensé à toi pour remettre césar de la
meilleure adaptation et l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est juste de se filmer des
petites improvisations tu vas très
simple voiture que tu puisse réagir si
jamais il ya un truc et maintenant on
touche pas les cheveux quand je te parle
jamais bien sûr c'est lui qui règle une
fois que tu puisses meublé au cas où
ok allez ça va aussi réfléchir aux
questions sur une impro tu rentres dans
un magasin de chaussures de luxe
tu crois que ton père tu lui fais une
crise au papa tu te rends compte de ce
que tu en train de me faire en sandales
de cuir et en chaussettes dans un
magasin comme ça à terre ajoute que
c'est souvent fait ta minh tu trouves à
tous les temps à faire dans certaines
pièces en magasin comme ça c'est trop
ok je te l'avais lorànt deutsch elle
tentait pas faire tâter car quand la
techno soffin allait super bretagne avec
lui et quand on a peur on va à quimper
il faut savoir qu'à quimper des
mérovingiens en 1920 en fait ce qui
s'est passé et c'est assez
impressionnant c'est qu'ils ont creusé
un métro souterrain sont qu'un belge je
m'en fous je m'en fous métronome je veux
pas que tu me parles de ça j'adore ce
week-end au foot d'accord il faut lâcher
du lest maintenant tu me lâches cette
montgolfière tu finis trajet le rodéo
qui est caché turba cyril hanouna la
radio beauté vous décidez ce nul à
tâtons imitation est d'accord sage pour
bosser dessus ça je te renvoie cette
ruche demain je te rouge très bien de ma
de ckoi pire aux seniors mais dit que ça
dit juste avant d'accord moi dont je
n'ai vu peu de failles étaient tout le
temps à ses considérants ouais on a fait
un super match bas esprit de collectifs
en tant que plein axe et pas pierre
favier meurtre elle a su les maillots
rester vigilant qu'il ya un problème de
la transmission certains à l'envers ça
qui est bien périodes bar sert pas en
avant maintenant c'est pire qu'un petit
jusqu'à laurent de monter puisque moi
j'ai une projet énorme attend là je peux
faire l'année un éléphant qui combine
franchement je te dis
pour le moment t'as pas les épaules pour
remettre en 16 heures je comprends qu'on
peut faire c'est que t'as qu'à tout
reprendre depuis le début caisse on a le
cuir sur cet opus afin d'accueillir
toutes les choses vont mal mesdames et
messieurs pierre
soir
bonsoir bonsoir cécile mais fortement de
merci merci à l'académie de m'avoir
finalement laissé ce césar vraiment
merci c'est un grand honneur c'était pas
gagné au début qu'est ce tu football est
complètement faux est-ce que tu sois
viré et moi je suis désolé d'intervenir
de couper la cérémonie mais non non non
non non non excusez moi il ya des choses
très importantes là au niveau des
évocations historiques le pire nier mais
il en a promis une dedans c'est pas
possible
les mérovingiens à quimper en 1920 j'en
connais pas alors pour une fois pour
toutes les mérovingiens
c'est lui 5e au 8e si on s'en fout et le
programme de 4e inscriptions sont fous
mais ce n'est pas drôle de nom
l'histoire de schiste c'est pas drôle
vous plaît sérieux on peut pas
improviser sur l'histoire de france un
bon jour c'est quelque chose dont des
emmerdes nom reste sur les imitations
d'accord pierre pas une mode mais c'est
bon merci afin de mater très bon match
tu peux faire mais la roma aussi donc je
veux pas refaire muriel robin je vous
remets t'en sers tu me fais chier là
excusez moi donc le césar de la
meilleure adaptation je ne suis pas
raciste mais mon avis ça ne fera pas
plaisir à ton père et les quelques
couleurs sinon je ne suis pas raciste
vous savez que le maire régis on s'en
fout là même sa femme tish et ça vient
du qatar et des rêves et nous avons
alors on s'en fout où est ce qu'on va là
pardon pardon mais c'est vrai que nous
on s'en foutait un petit peu alors